les rubans de tissus tourne quasiment 16
heures par jour pour cela deux équipes
se relaient nordine appartient à
l'équipe du matin
il est conducteur de ligne nous on a
vraiment une surveillance de la machine
un ravitaillement en fait on doit
effectuer un ravitaillement pour qu'elle
tombe jamais en rupture en fait est
qu'elle s'arrête jamais donc on est à
peu près sur une production de 150
masque à la minute
donc ce qui fait à peu près d'une 9000
masquer un peu près à l'heure on est sur
une production allez on va dire entre
les deux équipes on est à peu près à 100
mille masques sur une journée outre la
production locale
la coop des masques repose sur une
philosophie démocratique et sociale
chaque salarié est sociétaire chaque
citoyen qui y participent a également un
droit de regard et le recrutement se
fait sans véritable sélection dans l'adn
de la côte des masques on a essayé
d'avoir une mixité complète au niveau
des recrutements ce soit en termes
hommes femmes en termes personnes âgées
personnes plus jeunes et au niveau six
travailleurs reconnaissance un handicap
est donc aujourd'hui on a 30 % de nos
salariés qui sont en reconnaissance de
travailleur handicapé et avec les
recrutements à venir on va essayer de
garder ce niveau de travailleurs
handicapés
la structure continue d'embaucher d'ici
à septembre
elle devrait recruter sept nouvelles
personnes grâce notamment à l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle machine capable de
produire du miel blosne un filtre
extérieur au masque et seuls composants
encore importer on manque juste de
100000 euros pour pouvoir avoir cette
machine qu'on fait un appel à
mobilisation de tous les citoyens de
tous les sociétaires de tous les usagers
qui veulent participer à notre
entreprise
notre aventure coopérative et solidaire
il manque c'est cela pour qu'on puisse
avoir cette machine et devenir vraiment
fabricant de mel blanc pour notre propre
production mais aussi pour en vendre
industriels français tels que fabricant
de couches ou filtre de moteurs une
filière de recyclage et une production
de masques en matières végétales sont
également à l'étude
si la coop des masques compte
aujourd'hui 1900 sociétaires il faudrait
que ce nombre grossistes pour passer à
trois équipes par jour et mener à bien
l'ensemble de ces projets la dernière
entreprise française de fabrication de
masques à destination du personnel
médical et est elle aussi implanté dans
les côtes d'armor
lâché par l'état qui s'est désengagé de
ses commandes à la ferme et en 2018
trois ans plus tard laventure de la coop
des masques en terre bretonne sonne
comme une revanche du destin